the epitome of Hollywood glamour feigned
as much of a her love of duels as for
her love of husbands her relationship
with Richard Burton was arguably the
most tempestuous as he also showered her
with some of the most beautiful and
expensive pieces of jewelry in the world
one of the most stunning is this 33
carat diamond ring which person bought
for Elizabeth four years into their
first marriage it cost him around
200,000 pounds and has now gone up to
5.5 million he gave it to his wife in
1968 and she said to have worn it every
day until she died from the collection
is known as the crown jewels of
Hollywood and among the hundreds of
items for sale is this brooch which used
to be owned by King Edward the eighth's
wife Wallis Simpson Dame Elizabeth knew
the Duchess and tried to buy it offer
but was always refused she finally got
ahold of it in 1987 after Wallis Simpson
died and this diamond and Jade pendant
called the Taj Mahal which dates back to
the reign of a 16th century Emperor yet
another present from Richard Burton on
her 40th birthday however the most
impressive piece is the legendary 16th
century pearl at peregrina Burton bought
it for Elizabeth on Valentine's Day in
1969 and it was one of her favorites
discovered in the 1500s it became part
of the Spanish crown jewels and was also
owned by Mary Tudor I'm sending it now
Daphne but but this time it's true 10
million five hundred thousand dollars go
to you oh no attendee in five thank you
very much Elizabeth called it the most
perfect pearl in the world we knew it
would do well but no one dreamed that it
would bring 11 million dollars which is
a world-record price for a girl jewel
this is just the beginning with many
more of Elizabeth Taylor's
pieces to go on sale in what is already
the most valuable auction of jewelry
industry Lisa casa Sky News